let's say that something is traveling at
a constant rate of five meters per
second that's its velocity in one
dimension if it was negative would be
moving to the left if it's positive it's
moving to the right and let's say that
we we care about what is our change in
what is our change in distance over
would this the Delta symbol represents
change over a change in time of four
seconds over four seconds and I could
say from T equals zero to T is equal to
four that's our change in time that's
our four second interval that we care
about well one way to think about it is
well a rate a rate by definition is
nothing but a change in some quantity in
this case its distance over over a
change in some other quantity in this
case we're thinking about time or
another way to think about it if we
multiply both time both sides times
change in time you get your change in
distance is equal to your rate is equal
to your rate times change in time rate
times change in time and so this is very
close to you might remember from
pre-algebra distance is equal to rate
times time and that just comes from in
the definition of what a rate is it's a
change in one quantity with respect to
another quantity and so if you just
apply this if you say okay my rate is a
constant five meters per second and my
delta T is I'm as four seconds so times
four seconds well that's just going to
give you 20 that's just going to get you
20 let me do that same color that I had
for the for the change in distance
that's going to be 20 and then the
seconds cancel with seconds 20 meters so
my total change in distance over those
four seconds is going to be 20 meters
nothing new here nothing too fancy what
I want to do now is connect this to the
area under the rate function over this
time period so let's graph that let's
graph it so that's my rate axis this is
my time axis this is going to be in
seconds this is going to be in meters
per second so let's see one two three
four five that seems about enough and
then I go one two three four five our
rate at least in this example is a
constant is a constant five meters per
second it's a constant five meters per
second so that is my R of T in this
example and so what did we just do here
we just multiplied our change in time
times our constant rate we just
multiplied our change in time so it was
from time equals zero seconds to four
seconds so it's this length here if we
think of it on that axis and we
multiplied it times our constant rate we
multiplied it times this right over here
well if I multiply this base times this
height what am I going to get I'm going
to get the area under I am going to get
this area under the rate function and
that area is going to be 20 and if we
went with the units of them obviously
you're used to things of area being
something you know units squared because
it's usually you know meters times
meters or miles times miles or inches
times inches would be inches squared
meters squared or mile squared but here
if we go with the units of the axes it
would be meters per second times seconds
which is going to get you meters but the
important thing here is that the units
here or the area here is 20 so least for
that very simple example it looks like
the area under the rate curve is equal
to the net change over that time period
where the rate is something with respect
where we're saying that the rate of
something with respect to time but let's
test that a little bar let's just get a
little more intuition here
let's say that we had a different rate
function let's say that let me make it
with a different let's say instead we
had a rate function I'll still use
yellow let's say I have a rate function
that is let me make it a little bit
interesting let's say it's one meter per
second for our time is greater than or
equal or zero is less than or equal to
time which is less than or equal to two
seconds and
and this is obviously this is all in
seconds when we're talking about time
and there's two meters per second 40 is
greater than two seconds so what's that
going to look like and actually try to
graph it yourself and just say well what
is the total change in distance over the
first let's say five seconds so we want
to do delta T over the first four
seconds but the first five seconds
well let's graph it let's graph it so
this is one meter per second one meter
per second that is two meters per second
it's in meters per second that's my rate
axis and and this right over there is
going to be my that's going to be my
time axis one they're obviously not at
the same scale three four five and what
is this what does this rate function
look like
well my rate is one meter per second
between time is zero and two including
two seconds and then the rate jump so
this isn't that realistic nothing can
accelerate instantly like this you would
need an infinite force or an infinitely
small mass I guess to well maybe there's
some things if we think about well
anyway I don't get too complex there but
it this is unrealistic more but it's not
typical for something to to just have an
instantaneous velocity increase like
that but let's just go with it
so so then after the two seconds we are
at a constant we are at a constant rate
of two meters per second now what is our
total change in distance over the first
five seconds here so here we care about
the first five seconds well we can break
up the problem we could say well over
the first two seconds change in time is
two seconds times R we have a constant
rate over those two seconds so it's
going to be two seconds times one meter
per second well that's going to be
that's going to give us two meters so
this here is going to be actually let me
do that orange color that's going to
give us two meters there and then we
look at the next section our change in
time here is three seconds and then we
multiply that times our constant to me
per second that's going to give us an
area of six and if we look at the units
in both cases we're multiplying seconds
times meters per second which is going
to give us meters so it's going to be 2
plus 6 meters or 8 meters so hopefully
this is giving you the intuition that
the area under the rate curve or the
rate function is going to give you our
total net change in whatever that rate
thing was it was finding the rate of in
this case it is distance per unit time
if you if you take the area under the
rate function that that kind of distance
per this the speed or this velocity
function over some period of time that
area is going to be our total net change
in distance